bonsoir
bonsoir madame guérard jusqu'à quel
point la sdat borce très heureux de vous
recevoir à l'émission c'est la première
fois que vous êtes en zone économie
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
jusqu'à quel point la cinquième vague et
ses restrictions vous affecte en ce
moment est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'annulations
ben c'est sûr que la pandémie a eu un
impact dévastateur sur les compagnies
aériennes dans le monde transact n'a pas
été épargnée et je peux dire qu au
micro-ondes puis les mesures qui ont été
mises en place vont c'est clair ma venue
ajouter une couche par dessus tout nous
on était en reprise progressive depuis
le mois de juillet dernier jusqu'à la mi
décembre
puis on a dû gérer des dizaines de
milliers d'annulations de la part des
consommateurs ça s'est fait très
rapidement à partir de la mi-décembre
et bien sûr les réservations ont chuté
de manière drastique alors qu'on était
vraiment rendu le dans la pointe d'hiver
au niveau des réservations là quand on
regarde les patrouilles de booking alors
ça a été très très difficile pour nous
la saison mer ont été en partie pas mal
en grande partie plate et et
on croit tout main toutefois que l'été
qui s'en vient
va être bien mais pour ça c'est certain
qu'il faut qu'un assouplissement des
mesures qui sont aux frontières entre mc
et à un relâchement
rapidement pour icône et un plan de
visibilité pour savoir qu'est ce qui
semble dans les prochaines semaines pour
vous qualifier vous demandez quoi
exactement par rapport aux frontières il
ya encore des tests à l'arrivée il ya
encore des attentes qui encore les des
avis sur les voyages non-essentiels
qu'est-ce que vous demander au
gouvernement du canada
bennoo chez transat depuis le début de
la pandémie on a toujours été vraiment
en accord avec la mise en place de
mesures pour protéger la santé des
canadiens ont bien sûr on s'y opposer
port on pense toutefois que lorsqu'on
regarde aujourd'hui l'évolution de la
situation quand les tendres avant les
mesures en place que c'est important
qu'ils en ce sens toute notre industrie
et a besoin de visibilité sur les étapes
à venir
lisibilité pour nous pour les
transporteurs mais également visibilité
pour les consommateurs qui désirent
voyager après deux ans je pense que tout
le monde envie d'aller un peu s'évader
reconnecter ensemble puis les voyages le
les vacances sont là pour ça donc nous
demandent
d'abord ce qu'on cherche à voir c'est
vraiment le retrait de la vie qui est
dit qu canadien donc leur être de la vie
fédérale oui dit aux canadiens d'éviter
tout voyage non essentiel donc ce direct
c'est vraiment celui là il est quand
même assez majeur ensuite on croit qu'il
est temps de retirer également
l'obligation pour les voyageurs
canadiens pleinement vacciner de faire
un test de dépistage pour rentrer au
canada donc ça c'est vrai alors un
groupe une offre s'cusez moi
l'expression l'homme et pour les gens
qui sont à destination
et donc ce jeu reste une autre étape
l'autre étape c'est on n'a pas vraiment
problème avec le fait qu'ils aient des
tests de dépistage à l'arrivée au canada
mais de dépistage aléatoire à l'arrivée
au canada mais sans d'avoir s'isoler en
attente de résultats on prenait un repas
quatre personnes qui sont venues de
voyages d'être allé visiter de la
famille en europe ils reviennent et ne
reçoivent pas leurs résultats positifs
ou négatifs
et la plupart du temps négatif avant
cinq ou six jours sept jours donc pour
nous ça ça n'a pas de bon sens ça
décourage complètement les gens ça
décourage tout interne offre comme vous
dites est ce que est ce que même pour la
semaine de relâche en ce moment
vous avez peu de quel est le niveau de
réservation vous avez pour la semaine de
relâche qui est quand même généralement
pour transat un moment important
beaucoup de gens veulent aller dans le
sud
c'est comme le reste de l'hiver
l'incertitude les mesures en place ont
eu un impact surtout l'hiver donc
incluant les semaines de relâche de mars
les mesures aux frontières n'ont pas été
encore revanche et donc on l'annoncé la
semaine dernière on a dû réduire notre
capacité de façon importante c'est
vraiment dingue 2 % sur l'ensemble de
l'hiver donc motiver les hypothèques qui
veut pas aujourd'hui l'hypothèque est il
temps donné les urnes étant d'être le
ravage
étant donné le ravage depuis deux ans
comment votre transat parce que transat
traverser quand même beaucoup de
turbulences depuis deux ans vous avez
payé devant dupuis bon finalement ça n'a
pas été le cas aujourd'hui est-ce que
transat s'en sort résiste
votre capable de continuer sa route
mais on a eu c'est sûr qu'on a été
fortement on a eu un impact très fort au
niveau de la crise est allé toucher
notre trésorerie nous liquidités puis
les résultats qu'on a dévoilé au cours
de la dernière année je pense qu'en
témoignent très bien des résultats qu'on
ne pouvait jamais imaginé avoir chez
transat jamais ou empêchement on avait
une excellente situation on était en
bonne situation de liquidités avant le
début de la crise qui nous a aidés et
qui nous a fait gagner du temps pendant
plusieurs mois maintenant après un autre
crise après deux suspensions ça c'est en
fait laurent 2 en crise mais de
suspension des opérations alors
suspendre les opérations
si relativement facile repartir c'est
quelque chose d'autre surtout quand la
plupart des des pilotes ont perdu leur
certification donc ça a été un casse
tête énorme avec des coûts énormes dans
la formation
bon on aura ce soutien financier dont
l'aide fédérale qui nous a été
nécessaire pour absorber tout ce chat
est comme ça a été le cas dans pour
plusieurs compagnies aériennes midi
hélas elle était bien parti je voudrais
depuis juillet dernier donc à l'été mais
bon un micro est venu frapper à nouveau
et dans et on veut présenter nos
résultats trimestriels trimestriel au 10
mars prochain ok on va maintenant en
mesure de chiffrer un peu l'impact mais
c'est sûr que c'est pas des bonnes
nouvelles
c'est clair c'est pas c'est vraiment pas
simple madame guérard merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir c'est très apprécié ça
me fait très plaisir pour voir nos
émissions non tu y es rendez vous sur la
chaîne i see her dit